양자 컴퓨터를 사용하면 고전 컴퓨터만으로는 풀기 어려운 문제들을 더 빠르게 해결할 수 있을 거라고 생각해요. 하지만
그게 어떻게 가능한지는 좀 복잡해요. 오늘 Qiskit in the Classroom에서는 양자 컴퓨팅의
강력함의 근원을 찾아보기 위해 아주 초기의
알고리즘 중 하나를 살펴볼 거예요. Qiskit in the Classroom에 오신 걸 환영해요. 이 시리즈에서는 Qiskit을 활용해서 양자 컴퓨팅 관련 강의에서
자주 다루는 핵심 개념들을 탐구해 볼 거예요. 각 영상에는 인터랙티브 모듈이 함께 제공되는데
아래 설명란에 링크가 있으니 꼭 확인해 보세요. 양자 컴퓨터에 대해 조금이라도 들어보셨다면
중첩, 얽힘, 간섭 같은 양자 현상을 이용해서
고전 컴퓨터로는 풀 수 없는 문제를 해결할 수 있다는 얘기를 들어보셨을 거예요. 그런데 이런 특성들이 정확히 어떻게 도움이 될까요? 1985년, David Deutsch가
이게 어떻게 가능한지 처음으로 보여줬어요. 그는 지금 Deutsch의 알고리즘이라고 불리는 것을 만들었는데, 고전
알고리즘보다 더 효율적으로 문제를 풀 수 있었어요. 오늘은 Deutsch의 알고리즘과
그 이후에 나온 확장 버전인 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘을 살펴보고, qubit의 순수하게 양자적인 측면이
양자 컴퓨터에 어떻게 활용될 수 있는지 알아볼 거예요. 그런 다음 Qiskit으로 실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 이 알고리즘들을 실행해 볼게요.
알려진 고전 알고리즘보다 이론적 우위를 보이는 다른 양자 알고리즘들도 있어요. 그리고 그 모든 것들이
오늘 볼 것들과 같은 원리로 작동하는 건 아니에요. 그래서 오늘 배우는 내용이 일반적으로 양자
컴퓨터가 어떻게 작동하는지를 설명하진 않지만, 양자역학의 원리들이 어떻게 결합되어
강력한 양자 컴퓨터를 만드는지 이해하는 데 도움이 돼요. Deutsch의 알고리즘을 본격적으로 살펴보기 전에, 먼저 양자 컴퓨터가
고전 컴퓨터와 어떻게 다른지, 그리고 특정 문제를 푸는 데 있어 어떤 장점이
있는지 생각해 봐요. 한 가지 차이점은 qubit이라고 불리는 양자 비트가 중첩 상태에 있을 수 있다는 거예요. 고전 비트처럼
0 상태나 1 상태 중 하나에만 제한되는 게 아니라, qubit은
0과 1의 중첩 상태에 있을 수 있어요. 이 상태를 이렇게 표현하는데,
a와 b는 제곱의 합이 1이 되는 복소수예요. 그리고
qubit이 많아질수록 이 격차는 더 커져요. 2비트는 여전히 이 네 가지
가능한 상태 중 하나에만 있을 수 있어요. 00, 01, 10, 또는 1
1이죠. 반면 2개의 qubit은 고전적으로 허용되는 네 가지 상태 모두의 중첩 상태에 있을 수 있는데, 이렇게
표현해요. 일반적으로 n비트의 고전 시스템은 2의 n승 가지 0과 1의 조합 중 딱 하나의 상태에만 있을 수 있어요.
반면 n개의 qubit로 이루어진 양자 시스템은 2의 n승 가지 상태 모두의 중첩 상태에 있을 수 있어요.
스케일링이 지수적이에요. 그래서 qubit이 10개만 있어도
2의 10승, 즉 1,024가지 가능한 0과 1의 조합의 중첩 상태에
있을 수 있어요. qubit 상태 공간의 이런 지수적 스케일링을 양자
병렬성이라고 하는데, 이게 고전 컴퓨터에 비해 양자 컴퓨터가 갖는 장점의 일부 원인이에요. 하지만 양자
컴퓨터는 단순히 대규모 병렬 프로세서가 아니에요. 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit이 지수적으로 많은 상태의 중첩 상태에 있을 수 있다는 게
곧 각 상태의 모든 정보에 접근할 수 있다는 의미는 아니에요.
측정을 하면 시스템이 하나의 상태로 붕괴되니까요. 간단한 문제를 통해
이게 어떻게 나타나는지 살펴봐요. 단일 비트를
입력할 수 있는 어떤 기계가 있다고 해봐요. 그러면 기계는 그 비트에 어떤 함수를 적용해서 또 다른 단일 비트를 출력해요. 이 기계는
우리가 접근할 수 없는 블랙박스 안에 있어요. 우리가 접근할 수 있는 건
우리가 입력하는 비트 x와 박스가 출력하는 비트 f
(x)뿐이에요. 우리는 기계가 적용하고 있는 함수 f가 뭔지 알아내고 싶어요.
단일 비트를 또 다른 단일 비트로 변환하는 가능한 함수는 네 가지예요.
그래서 함수가 뭔지 알아내려면 0을 입력해서 0이 나오는지 1이 나오는지 확인한 다음,
1을 입력해서 같은 걸 확인하면 돼요. 이 두 단계 각각을 쿼리라고 해요.
이게 고전 알고리즘과 양자 알고리즘을 비교하는 한 가지 방법인데, 소위 쿼리 모델이라고 하고, 문제를 풀기 위해
각 알고리즘이 블랙박스에 몇 번 쿼리해야 하는지 비교해요. 그러니까 이 경우에
고전적인 방법은 함수를 알아내기 위해 박스에 두 번 쿼리해야 했어요. 양자 컴퓨터로 블랙박스에 쿼리하면 더 잘할 수 있는지 봐요.
먼저 0을 입력하고 그다음 1을 입력하는 대신,
양자 컴퓨터는 0과 1의 중첩 상태에 있는 qubit을 박스에 입력할 수
있어요. 그러면 사실상 단 한 번의 쿼리로 박스에 두 입력값을 모두 넣는 거예요. 그렇다면
단 한 번의 쿼리로 함수를 알아낼 수 있다는 뜻일까요?
안타깝게도 그렇지 않아요. 양자 컴퓨터에서 테스트해보면 이 아이디어가 왜 실패하는지 알 수 있어요. 두 개의 qubit으로
circuit을 만들 거예요. 이 맨 위 선으로 표현된 qubit 0이 블랙박스에 입력하는 입력 상태 X가 될 거예요.
블랙박스는 UF라고 표시된 진한 빨간색 gate로 표시돼요. UF gate는
qubit 0을 입력 상태 X로 받아서 qubit 1에 변환을 적용하도록
설계되어 있는데, 상태 0을 상태 f(x)로 변환해요. 그래서 qubit 1이 상태
0에서 시작하는 한, 출력은 qubit 0에서 x이고 qubit 1에서 f(x)예요. 그러면 x=0과
x=1 모두에 대해 동시에 f(x)를 구하기 위해, 블랙박스에 넣기 전에 qubit 0을 0과 1의 중첩 상태로 만들어 볼 수 있어요.
이 빨간색 Hadamard gate로 하는데, 0 상태를 1/√2 곱하기
(|0⟩ + |1⟩)로 변환해요. 그러면 블랙박스 gate 이후에 qubit 1에서 f(0)과 f(1) 모두의 중첩 상태를 얻어야 해요. 두 qubit을 측정할 때,
블랙박스 안에 어떤 함수가 있는지 알아내길 바라는 거예요. Qiskit의 primitive Sampler를 사용해서
circuit을 실행하고 결과를 반환해 봐요. circuit이 실행되는 횟수를 샘플이라고 하는데,
여기 shots라는 이 파라미터를 변경해서 횟수를 선택할 수 있어요.
shots 파라미터가 바로 여기 있어요.
이건 블랙박스에 쿼리하는 횟수와 같아요. 단 한 번의 쿼리로도
될지 봐요. 결과가 나왔어요. qubit 0은 0으로 측정됐어요. 그게
입력값 x였고 qubit 1은 1로 측정됐는데, 출력값 f(x)였어요. 이제
f(0)=1이라는 걸 알았어요. 그런데 f(1)은요? 바로 여기서 문제가 생겨요.
상태를 측정하자마자 중첩이 붕괴되었고, 단 한 번의 쿼리로 함수의 한 부분만 측정할 수 있었어요.
이걸로는 어떤 함수인지 파악하는 데 필요한 모든 걸 알 수 없어요. 그러려면 박스에
두 번째 쿼리가 필요해요. 그러니까 양자 병렬성의 원리 덕분에 동시에
블랙박스가 f(0)과 f(1)을 계산하게 할 수 있지만, 두 답 모두에
접근할 수는 없어요. 양자 병렬성만으로는 충분하지 않아요. Deutsch의 알고리즘은
양자 병렬성을 조금 다르게 활용해서 블랙박스 안의 함수에 대해 알아낼 수 있는 방법을 보여줘요.
함수가 정확히 뭔지는 알 수 없지만, 단 한 번의 쿼리로 고전 컴퓨터로는
할 수 없는 방식으로 함수에 대한 새로운 정보를 알 수 있어요. 단일 비트를 또 다른 단일 비트로 변환하는
네 가지 가능한 함수의 표부터 살펴봐요. 여기서 함수 f_sub_1과 f_sub_4 두 개는 입력 상태에 관계없이 항상
하나의 값만 반환한다는 걸 볼 수 있어요. 이 두 함수를
상수 함수라고 해요. f_sub_2와 f_sub_3는 x의 상태에 따라 0 또는 1을
반환해요. 이 두 함수는 균형 함수라고 해요. Deutsch의 알고리즘은
함수가 상수인지 균형인지 판별하는데, 이전에 사용한 circuit에 몇 가지 영리한 조정을 가해서
해요. 여기 circuit이 있어요. qubit 0을 이전처럼 Hadamard로 1/√2 곱하기
(|0⟩ + |1⟩) 상태로 준비하고 qubit 1은 NOT gate에 이어 Hadamard로 1/√2 곱하기 (|0⟩ -
|1⟩) 상태로 준비해요.
그러면 이 시점에서 전체 상태는 이렇게 되는데, 이게 qubit 0의 상태이고
이게 qubit 1의 상태예요. qubit 1을 단순히 0 상태로 두는 게 아니라 이런 방식으로 준비하면
알고리즘이 양자 병렬성을 간섭과 결합해서 블랙박스 함수에 대해 알아낼 수 있어요.
qubit들이 UF 블랙박스 gate에 입력될 때 어떤 일이 일어나는지 봐요. 함수가 상수이면 블랙박스는
0의 상태와 관계없이 qubit 1에만 어떤 연산을 수행해요.
이 경우 UF가 qubit 0을 건드리지 않고 그 상태를 전혀 신경 쓰지 않으니까, 여기 두 번째 Hadamard가
첫 번째 Hadamard가 한 것을 되돌려요. 그러면 qubit이 0 상태로 측정돼요. 균형 함수 f_sub_2를 예로 들어
이 경우 UF가 상태에 무슨 일을 하는지 살펴봐요. x가 0이면 f(x)는 0이고, x가
1이면 f(x)는 1이에요. UF gate에 대해 말씀드린 걸 기억하세요. qubit 0을
입력 x 상태로 받아서 f(x)를 qubit 1에 출력해요. qubit 1이
0 상태에서 시작한다고 가정하면요. 그러면 이 함수에서 UF가 qubit 1에 하는 일은
qubit 0에 달려 있어요. 0이 0이면 qubit 1은 0 상태로 남아서 f
(x)=0을 얻어요. qubit 0이 1이면 블랙박스는 qubit 1에 NOT gate를 적용해서
1 상태로 만들어요. 그러면 f(1)=1이 돼요. 이게 바로 controlled-NOT, 즉 CNOT gate가 하는 일이에요.
CNOT gate는 두 개의 qubit을 받는데, control qubit과 target qubit이 있어요. control qubit이 1 상태에 있으면 target qubit의
상태를 뒤집어요. 하지만 control qubit이 0 상태에 있으면
target에는 아무것도 하지 않아요. 그러니까 F2에 대한 UF는 Q0과 Q1에 대한 CNOT일 뿐이에요.
CNOT gate는 control qubit이 0 상태이므로 첫 번째 항에는 아무것도 하지 않아요. 하지만 두 번째 항에서 이
0은 1로 뒤집히고 이 1은 0으로 뒤집혀요. 마이너스 부호를 인수분해하면 qubit 1의 상태는
변하지 않았다는 걸 볼 수 있어요. 하지만 이 항에는 마이너스 부호가 붙었어요. 그러니까 실제로 변한 건 qubit 0의
상태예요. |0⟩ + |1⟩에서 |0⟩ -
|1⟩로 바뀐 거예요. qubit 0에 마지막 Hadamard를 적용하면 1 상태로 변환돼요. 그러면 블랙박스 안의 함수가
f_sub_2이면 0 대신 1로 측정돼요. 다른 균형 함수 f3에 대한 UF gate는
같은 CNOT gate에 이어 qubit 1에 NOT을 적용한 거예요. 그 마지막 NOT gate는 qubit 0에 영향을 주지 않아요. 그래서 함수가
균형이면 circuit 끝에서 qubit 0이 1 상태로 측정돼요. 이 내용을 다 따라오지 못하셨다면
괜찮아요. 직접 살펴보면서 어떻게 작동하는지 확인해 보세요. 여기서 핵심은
두 균형 함수에 대해 CNOT을 적용했을 때 무슨 일이 일어났냐는 거예요. qubit 0은 qubit 1의 상태를 바꾸기 위한
control qubit으로만 사용됐어요. 직관적으로는 qubit 0이 변하지 않을 거라고 생각할 수 있어요. 그런데 어떻게든
qubit 1에 대한 연산이 실제로 qubit 0의 중첩 상태의 두 부분 사이의 상대적 위상을 바꾸면서
qubit 0의 상태를 변화시켜요. 이 현상을 위상 킥백 메커니즘이라고 하는데
많은 양자 현상들처럼 굉장히 반직관적이에요. 어떤 면에서는 위상 킥백 메커니즘을
배를 젓는 것에 비유할 수 있어요. 물을 뒤로 밀면 실제로 앞으로 나아가게 되는 것처럼, qubit 1에 대한 연산이
실제로 qubit 0을 바꾸는 것과 마찬가지예요. 이제 Qiskit에서 Deutsch의 알고리즘을 실행해 볼 수 있어요.
여기서 블랙박스 안에 넣을 함수를 선택할 수 있고 F3를 선택했어요. 여기
알고리즘의 circuit 다이어그램이 있고 이전처럼 sampler primitive로 실행할 수 있어요. 샘플 수를
1로만 설정하고 어떻게 측정되는지 봐요.
샘플을 1로만 설정하고 어떻게 측정되는지 봐요. 이 경우 1로 측정됐어요.
그러니까 함수가 균형이라는 걸 알았고, 블랙박스가 함수 f3를 포함하고 있으니 예상한 결과예요. 단 한 번의
쿼리로 이 두 종류의 함수를 구별할 수 있었어요.
고전 알고리즘으로는 두 번의 쿼리가 필요했을 거예요. 이건 양자 컴퓨팅이
고전 컴퓨팅에 비해 갖는 소소한 장점을 보여주지만, 그다지 인상적이진 않아요. 1 대 2에 불과하니까요. 하지만 Deutsch의 알고리즘은
양자 컴퓨팅의 역사에서 여전히 매우 중요한데, 다른 사람들이 더 크고 정교한 양자 알고리즘을 생각하게 된
불씨가 되어줬기 때문이에요.
여기에는 훨씬 더 인상적인 양자 우위를 보여주는 Deutsch 알고리즘의 다중 qubit 확장 버전도 포함돼요.
바로 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘이에요. 비슷한 문제를 풀지만, 이 경우 우리가 알아내고자 하는 블랙박스 함수는
n비트를 입력으로 받아서 단일 비트를 출력해요.
이전처럼 함수가 상수이거나 — 즉 입력 비트 문자열과 관계없이 출력 비트가 항상 1이거나 항상 0이거나 —
균형이라고 약속해요. 균형이란 입력 비트 문자열의 절반에 대해서는 출력이 0이고
나머지 절반에 대해서는 1이라는 뜻이에요. 물론 n비트를 단일 비트로 변환하는
다른 함수들도 있는데, 상수도 균형도 아닌 것들이에요. 하지만 이 문제에서는
그런 함수들은 블랙박스 안에 없다고 약속해요. 박스 안의 함수는 반드시 상수이거나
균형이에요. Deutsch-Jozsa circuit은 Deutsch의 알고리즘과 비슷하지만 qubit이 더 많아요. 여기
3비트 함수를 알아내기 위한 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘 구현이 있어요. 이번에는 qubit이 세 개
입력 상태에 사용되는데, 하나만 쓰는 게 아니에요. 그리고 이 마지막 qubit이 출력 상태를 위한 거예요. 이전처럼
모든 입력 qubit을 |0⟩ + |1⟩ 상태로 준비하고 출력 qubit은
|0⟩ - |1⟩ 상태로 준비해요. 그러면 수학이 좀 더 복잡해지지만 원리는
동일해요. 함수가 상수이면 위쪽 세 qubit에 전혀 의존하지 않아요. 그래서 그것들의 상태는
두 번째 Hadamard들 이후에 다시 0으로 변환되고, 측정 결과는 모두 0인 3비트 문자열이 나와요.
하지만 함수가 균형이면 Hadamard들 이후에 qubit을 측정할 때 위상 킥백
메커니즘이 그 비트들 중 하나 이상을 1로 만들어요. 이번엔 쉽게 보이지 않을 수 있지만, 직접 각 단계를 따라가 보면
이게 맞다는 걸 알 수 있을 거예요. 이걸 확인하는 한 가지 방법은 균형 함수로 모두 0이 측정될
확률을 계산해 보는 거예요. 확률이 0이 나올 거예요. Qiskit으로 양자 컴퓨터에서
Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘을 실행해 봐요. 가장 어려운 단계는 아마 Deutsch-Jozsa
함수를 만드는 거예요. 이게 여기서 쿼리할 블랙박스가 돼요. 이 코드는 반드시 균형이거나 상수인
랜덤 Deutsch-Jozsa 함수를 만들어요. 그런 다음 블랙박스 함수를 여기 삽입해서
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit을 만들어요. 마찬가지로 sampler로 circuit을 실행하고 측정 후에
측정된 비트들을 보고 함수가 균형인지 상수인지 판별해요.
모두 0이면 상수예요. 하지만 문자열에 1 비트가 하나라도 있으면 균형이에요. 이
경우 1 1 1 비트 문자열이 나왔어요.
그러니까 함수가 균형이라는 걸 알았어요. 양자 알고리즘이 어떻게 흥미롭고 종종 미묘한 양자 현상을
활용해서 고전 알고리즘에 비해 우위를 얻는지 처음으로 엿볼 수 있었기를
바라요. 양자 알고리즘을 설계하는 게 얼마나 까다로운지도 느끼셨을 거예요. 아주 처음 나온
알고리즘조차도 고전적인 방법에 비해 소소한 우위를 달성하기 위해 많은 창의성이 필요했어요. 그리고 그 첫 번째 알고리즘 이후로
물리학자들과 컴퓨터 과학자들은 양자역학을 활용하는 믿을 수 없을 만큼 창의적인 방법들을 계속 만들어 왔어요.
Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘의 추가 확장 및 응용을 포함해서요. 이것들에 대해
알아보고 싶거나 Deutsch 및 Deutsch-Jozsa 알고리즘을 직접 해보고 싶다면,
설명란에 링크된 모듈로 가서 시작해 보세요. 시청해 주셔서 감사하고 다음에 또 봬요.